- [Instructor] In discussing
political socialization,
we've talked a lot about
factors that go into how people
develop their opinions on
government and politics.
Your family, your friends, your
demographic characteristics,
like your race, your gender,
they all contribute to your views.
In this video, I wanna talk
about another set of factors
that influence a person's political views,
and that's political events.
And political events include
not just elections or debates
or laws, but things
like terrorist attacks,
or international incidents,
or economic recessions.
These are external events
that shape a person's beliefs,
either in the short-term or maybe even
for the rest of their lives.
So what are some examples
of how political events
influence ideology?
Some events can change a
person's party identification
or how strongly they
identify with a party.
For example, researchers
have found that people
who lost family members
in the September 11th
terrorist attacks became
more politically active
and have identified more strongly
with the Republican party since then.
Sometimes events can
influence a person's attitudes
toward government and the
political process as a whole.
And here we're not talking
about which party a person
favors, but rather their
ideas about government itself,
like is the government trustworthy?
Does my vote really count?
One example of this is
the lasting influence
of the Vietnam War and Watergate scandal
on public trust in government.
You can see in this graph
by the Pew Research Center
that since polls started asking
Americans whether they trust
Washington to do what is right
always or most of the time,
trust peaked in the early
Johnson administration,
then crashed in the mid-1960s and 1970s
and has never really recovered since.
So events that happened more
than 50 years ago have left
a mark on public trust in
government that hasn't gone away.
But not all political events have
such a lasting effect on beliefs.
Some events influence opinions
for just a short term,
like international events that influence
Americans' attitudes
towards other countries.
For example, you can see in
this poll data done by Gallup,
that the public's favorable
opinion about Russia has changed
a great deal over the last 20 years,
with revelations about
Russian hacking coming in 2015
leading to a sharp decline
in favorable opinions.
The last thing I wanna note
here is that researchers
have discovered that
political events that happen
when someone is in their
formative age, or the age
from about 18 to 24, when
people are just getting out
on their own and starting to
form an independent identity.
Events that happen then are
more likely to have long lasting
effects on a person's political
beliefs and behaviors.
The great recession in 2008
had a strong effect on people
in the millennial generation,
many of whom were just getting
out into the workforce when it hit.
Studies have shown that
this had an especially
strong influence on their
ideas about government
and money compared to other generations.
So events can have both
short and long-term effects
on people's political beliefs,
not just about whether
they lean more liberal or conservative,
but also about how they think
about government itself.
And those effects may be
felt more strongly depending
on what stage a person is in their life
or how deeply an event
impacts them personally.